oh yes the first video of the new year
happy New Year to everybody you've seen
my top ten favorite movies in 2017 my
top 10 worst movies of 2017 now I'm
gonna talk about my top 10 anticipated
movies of 2018 coming up but first
spaulding so sure this video was
sponsored by audible home to the largest
selection of digital audio books
including bestsellers no releases
exclusives and much more on that in a
bit but for now let's talk about my 10
anticipated movies of 2018 thing to
remember here is they're not in any
particular order I think they're an
order of release for the most part
anyway so it's not like the first one I
say is 10 there's no ten nine eight
seven six two one things going down the
air pick 10 movies now let's start with
the first one the first one I'm looking
forward to is ready player one directed
by Steven Spielberg based on a book it
tells of a world where you go into a VR
world and it's just everything we love
his nerds I watched the trailer I was
like okay that's a lot of copyrighted
property well when I saw the DeLorean
pop I was like really the DeLorean time
machine him back to the future for
nothing else I'm curious about this
movie I think it's in good hands with
Steven Spielberg Steven Spielberg has a
way of bringing the magic granted that
dude has made some garbage also but he's
made some great stuff great stuff that
this looks like it harkens back to next
on the list is the New Mutants new mean
it looks like something different it's
like the x-men universe but horror movie
which you look at mutant powers in x-men
or some of those that would be scary at
this point we've seen the superhero
thing it's like every studio that has
superhero properties are trying to find
a different way to go about it like
they're like let's go full harm over
here I think there's a smart way to do
it an interesting way to do it it's a
direction I didn't expect anyone to take
with the x-men property and the mutants
thing and as much as every time I do a
list like this I'm always like alright
let's try to minimize the whole MCU
comic book movie thing but comic book
movies are definitely on here MC movies
there are a couple I'm looking forward
to I am Jeremy nice to meet you now I'll
be honest with you the trailers for
Black Panther look interesting but I'm
never like I need to see it right now
today but everything about black panther
is what I'm looking forward to it if
someone to come up to me and just give
me the information hey there's a movie
coming out starring Michael B Jordan
chadwick boseman Lupita Nyong'o and it's
directed by Ryan Coogler I'd be like I'm
in like I'm absolutely in the fact that
it takes place in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe just happens to be a wheelhouse
I enjoy that's just icing on the cake
there's a lot you can do with this I'm
just I'm kind of concerned at the fact
that Marvel seems to be going the more
comedic route these days
feel like ant-man and the wasp lends
itself to that more than Black Panther
oh say Avengers infinity war I'm looking
forward to Black Panther not just
looking forward to Black Panther I am
rooting for Black Panther speaking of
Avengers infinity war let's just roll
right into the next MCU movie I'm
looking for - that is Avengers infinity
war Avengers infinity war I feel like
it's gonna be a more straightforward
approach doom himself not dr. doom but
like the epitome of doom the apocalypse
not apocalypse but you know what I mean
whatever Thanos has come to earth so it
looks like the culmination of the
previous decade of MCU movies is all
leading to this this is how you can have
your team be divided after Captain
American Civil War and then come back
together to fight the common threat
directed by the Russos who did Captain
America Winter Soldier and Civil War
they've been crushing it if I have one
critique about those russo MCU movies
there's a bit more shaky-cam and the
action sequences then I generally tend
to like but isn't detract from the
movies as a whole if there's a team I
would like to direct Avengers infinity
war it would be the Russos they are
looking forward to this next up is
Deadpool - why because Deadpool one was
so good and so surprising so if I wasn't
looking forward to Deadpool - for me
that would be a bit strange they made
good on a promise they made in the
post-credits scene of Deadpool 1
Deadpool was like oh by the way we're
having cable coming in the next one
every some odd reason there was never
any doubt in anyone's mind that he was
telling the truth and out Cable is in
this one and he's played by Josh Brolin
who is also Thanos who was in Avengers
infinity war basically Josh Brolin has
taken up one-fifth of my anticipated
list of 2018 I hope Deadpool 2 doesn't
have a case of sequel itis where they
try to catch lightning in a bottle the
second time and they basically hang over
to it see what happens but for now
Deadpool 2 definitely looking forward to
it also coming up The Incredibles - we
got one breafast teaser trailer I don't
really know much about this movie but
what I do know is a Fantastic Four movie
cannot be made to save anyone's ass what
it happened it's called The Incredibles
I'd like to see a sequel to that cars
has gotten two sequels it's long overdue
that The Incredibles gets one The
Incredibles is one of my favorite Pixar
movies it is a textbook case of a movie
being sold solely on its name it's an
incredible sequel I'm completely there
next up is venom a big spider-man fan
also me big nineties spider-man fan
which means me as venom fan I love venom
what's more important as venom was
horribly done in spider-man 3 there was
what comic-con art where it was just
Venom's face that says we are venom or
something like that I told me nothing
about the movie except the fact he said
we and that got me excited because when
Topher Grace said I I was like not my
venom there's no spider-man
always professed that changes Venom's
character a bit for this because he
doesn't have that opposite like this is
a solid venom Mulligan that they're
doing so I am certainly interested next
up more comic book madness what you
think my list is gonna be seriously
don't feel yourself x-men The Dark
Phoenix because we haven't seen the Dark
Phoenix on screen not really I spend one
to our building to it Dark Phoenix
didn't get the representation it should
have gotten then after x-men apocalypse
we know it's going there and then Bryan
Singer I guess is not doing the movie so
we're kind of questioning it for a bit
but we're getting Dark Phoenix I can
tell you this if this movie sucks leave
us with New Mutants and we'll go on with
that next up is the sequel to a surprise
from a couple years ago we got Creed 2
coming I don't have my ear to the ground
on the inner workings of what's coming
out in movie lore I just know Creed 2 is
happening what I understand it's going
to deal with dragos sons so Creed's son
is going to take on the son of the guy
who killed his father so we could have a
really good sins of the father thing
though he'll probably want to rage out
on this do this dude actually didn't
have anything to do with the death of
his father and there's a lot they can do
there's a lot of character in here
possibility of character anyway that's
the thing of anything on this list what
I see are the possibilities all right no
video game movies on this list because
I've lost faith in all of them wreck-it
Ralph is not a video game movie neither
is the sequel Ralph breaks the internet
it's a great movie that uses video game
properties as the icing on the cake but
the cake of wreck-it Ralph is good and
I'm looking forward to this one folks
again no trailer whatsoever I hope a
trailer doesn't come out between me
filming this video and me uploading it
but with the success of wreck-it Ralph I
see the possibilities of a lot more
video game companies going yet you can
use our property hopefully they can work
out a lot of deals but they don't have
to make some of the characters look kind
of like some of the license video game
characters was not really the license
video game characters hopefully we can
have more lives in this video game
characters there'll be a lot of fun but
we'll see what happens but for now I
have given you 10 10 movies I'm looking
forward to in 2018 funny thing is if
this year is anything like last year my
favorites of the year gonna be things
that weren't even on my radar don't know
a lot about what's coming but what is
certain is there gonna be a lot of
surprises but first bombs so sure again
this video is brought to you by audible
follow the link below in the description
to audible.com slash John's get yourself
a 30 day free trial of audible browse
the largest audio book library in the
known galaxy and since ready player
one's coming out you can do ready player
one an audible at that point you can
listen to the audiobook be in on the
note and when you watch the movie you
can kind of judge what
was accurate what wasn't what properties
they had over here what properties they
didn't have over here properties were
swapped out you get to judge and this is
the Internet we're here to judge all
right so your 10 anticipated movies for
2018 whatever their comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]